un paso histórico para la economía
global tras un largo proceso de
negociación más de 130 países alcanzaron
un acuerdo para incrementar la
tributación de las multinacionales
globalmente sustituye al anuncio de la
ocde acaba de anunciar que hemos llegado
a un acuerdo sobre los parámetros
técnicos de la fiscalidad internacional
con 136 miembros de la ocde en acuerdo
incluidos todos los países del g20 y los
27 estados de la unión europea es una
excelente noticia luego de cuatro años
de intensas negociaciones en las que
francia de principio a fin jugó un papel
primordial porque la famosa suite de
hotel con yogur la iniciativa por un
lado estima que los derechos impositivos
sobre más de 125 mil millones de
ganancias se reasignen a las
jurisdicciones cada año adicionalmente
introduce una tasa impositiva mínima
global fijada en 15 por ciento que se
aplicará a aquellas empresas con
ingresos superiores a 750 millones de
euros y que estima generar 150 mil
millones de dólares en ingresos fiscales
globales anualmente esto la preocupación
para algunos países como irlanda donde
se asentó un gran número de gigantes
tecnológicos gracias a su política de
baja tributación james shifting cambió
al 15% probablemente aumentaría los
ingresos por impuestos corporativos pero
a mediano y largo plazo no está claro
qué pasaría somos un país pequeño con un
mercado más pequeño serán los países
grandes con muchos clientes los que se
beneficiarán de este camino fantástico
esta iniciativa será entregada en la
reunión de ministros de finanzas del g20
en washington el 13 de octubre y se
espera que los países firmen una
convención multilateral en 2022 para su
implementación en 2023